Finding scorpions in the desert at night
is surprisingly easy.
All you need is an ultraviolet torch
because scorpions are
incredibly fluorescent.
Fluorescence means their
bodies absorb ultraviolet light
and reradiate it in the
visible part of the spectrum.
They glow this bright neon green color.
But scorpions aren't the
only animals that fluoresce.
Jellyfish, amphibians,
owls, and even platypus'
glow under ultraviolet light.
Part of this video is sponsored
by Capital One Shopping.
More about them at the end of the show.
I'm out here in the desert
near Bakersfield, California,
looking for scorpions with Carl Kloock,
a professor of biology
at Cal State Bakersfield.
He's been researching
scorpion fluorescence
for over a decade.
- If you have a black light
it's really pretty easy.
If they're there, you're
going to spot them.
- [Derek] Does he look
like he's in a posture
to like defend himself?
- [Carl] Yeah, he's not real happy.
- [Derek] Okay.
(man chuckling)
- [Carl] I'm going to grab my high-tech
scorpion catching equipment here.
It's a tongue depressor with
a yellow highlighter on it.
So it fluoresces in black light.
So you can see where it is.
- [Derek] Got it.
(man chuckling)
- [Carl] This technique is usually to put
the vial behind him,
then in front of him.
- [Derek] That was impressive.
All right. Should we give it a shot?
- [Carl] Just gently pokes him back in.
And they usually just kind of do a little
side crab walk back.
There you go, and just tilt it up.
- [Derek] Unbelievable.
(man chuckles)
Unbelievable.
All right. I'm going to get him.
But why are scorpions fluorescent?
- I've got about 12 hypotheses.
So you test them one at a time.
- [Derek] You've got
12 Hypotheses about why
the scorpions fluoresce?
- More like six actually,
I was being a little bit...
Almost all scorpions fluoresce.
I haven't seen it myself,
but some that live at living
caves they don't fluoresce
but it's only like one very small group.
All the other scorpions fluoresce.
One possibility is just,
this is a Relic Trait.
It's something they developed way back
when they first came out on
land and just haven't lost.
A chemical that has another function
that just happens to fluoresce.
There are plenty of
chemicals that fluoresce.
I mean, we have internal
bodily fluids that fluoresce.
And clearly those are
never exposed to UV light.
So the idea of having a function
for that fluorescence is kind of silly.
This fluoresce is about the
same color as a scorpion,
but clearly isn't a scorpion.
It's actually a rock.
The color is a little off.
- [Derek] But that is like, what is that?
- It's plastic from Walpole.
- [Derek] Huh.
You anted to know if the
scorpions were fluorescing
in order to attract insects.
- Right.
- [Narrator] So how did you test that?
- What I did was I used preserved
scorpions like these ones
and I took half of them and dip them in
UV blocking marine varnish
so they didn't fluoresce.
And then I just used basically flypaper
and took those things outside
and set them side by side
and then found the
number of flying insects
that were caught in each.
- [Derek] Okay.
- [Carl] So we were outside in moonlight
and I did the same experiment,
both under the new moon and the full moon.
And so what I found from that was
when there was a new moon,
there was no difference in the number
of insects caught by the fluorescent
and non-fluorescent scorpions.
But under the full moon,
there's nice, bright UV light
available there was a difference
and the ones that fluoresce
actually caught fewer insects.
- It seems kind of counterintuitive.
- So that tells me that
my hypothesis was wrong.
Which happens a lot.
Basically yeah, they're not using
their fluorescence to lure insects.
In fact, the fluorescence is
a bad thing for them in terms
of their ability to catch
flying insects, at least.
- Let me ask you this.
If you find that fluorescence
is counterproductive
for the scorpion in some way,
doesn't that indicate that there
has to be something useful?
- Exactly. There must be
something that counteracts that.
- Sort of negative.
- That negative, yeah.
Scorpions are really well
adapted for what they do.
One of the cool things
here is it scorpions
are actually able to
metabolize iron and nickel.
And in their pincer here
and on the tips of their claws,
they actually have basically
iron to strengthen that.
- [Derek] Iron and nickel
at the end of their tail?
- [Carl] Yeah. Yeah.
You can see like the color
here's a little bit different
and that's because of the iron.
- [Derek] That seems
very aggressive to me.
One of the main things
we're interested in here
is how they see.
So I've seen two of their eyes.
- [Carl] So, those are the
median eyes right there.
- [Derek] Those two dark spots.
- [Carl] Yeah. There's a cluster
of three eyes right there.
And of course on the other
side, so they're symmetrical.
So they have a total of eight eyes.
- Can they detect the light
with parts of their body
that are not eyes?
- Yeah. Actually they can.
- [Derek] In a 1968 experiment,
researchers put scorpions in
half covered Petri dishes.
Then they exposed them to bright
light and all the scorpions
quickly hid under the covered
part of the Petri dish.
Then the researchers painted
over the eyes of the scorpions.
So they couldn't see and
repeated the experiment.
But when they turned on
the light, 93% of the time,
the blinded scorpions still scuttled over
to the covered side.
The finding was remarkable.
Scorpions don't need their
eyes to detect light.
They can sense it with their bodies.
- That showed that they have what's called
an extra ocular light sense in their tail.
So they can detect light with their tail.
They can't form images, they can't,
but they can detect light.
- The tail of a scorpion can detect light?
- One hypothesis is that they use it
to communicate with one another.
The idea being that
they use it to determine
primarily whether or not
another scorpion out there
is of the same species for mating.
One fairly low probability hypothesis
is that they can use it as camouflage
because they absorb UV light.
If they're sitting on another
surface that absorbs UV light
and you have an organism
that sees in the UV light
like some owls and
things like that can do,
they would tend to blend
in very nicely with that.
So it's a possibility,
but not that many organisms see in UV
and not that many that
eat scorpion, see in UV
so it doesn't seem very likely.
- [Derek] You go for it.
- [Carl] You want me to do it upclose?
- [Narrator] You do it.
- [Carl] Close.
Here you go. See?
There you go, wow.
- One of the ideas is
scorpions came out of the water
from Silurian period long time ago.
And there was a lot
more UV just in sunlight
and things like that then,
because we didn't have
an ozone layer, we didn't have, you know,
all these things that are
blocking UV in our atmosphere now.
And so the one of the idea is that
it actually acts as a sunscreen.
It's way to absorb those
damaging ultraviolet photons
and convert them away into something
and basically keep them from
penetrating into the body
and causing damage.
- [Derek] Go in your hole.
There you go.
You got him.
- And then there have been some other ones
that are a little bit more out there.
One of which being the one that I actually
settled on at the end is that they use it
as part of their sensory
system to detect the presence
of light in the environment.
So this was the later
experiment after I gave up
on the initial idea that
said that didn't work.
So, all I really did in
that one, very simple,
put a scorpion in each
one of these things here
and then put this under ultraviolet light
and exposed it to ultraviolet light.
And so I measured how
long they spent exposed
versus unexposed and how many times
they went back and forth.
- [Derek] And you were testing scorpions
that were fluorescent and not fluorescent.
- [Carl] Right.
So what I did with that was I developed
a technique to remove, or at least reduce
the ability of scorpions to fluoresce
simply by exposing them for long periods
of time to ultraviolet light.
So basically, you're just
kind of taking the chemical
that is causing fluorescence
in their exoskeleton
and your photo bleaching.
- [Derek] So you're kind
of breaking it down?
- [Carl] So basically,
you're making the chemical
not be able to function properly anymore.
What we found is the activity
levels changed significantly.
So when you exposed to UV light,
the non-fluorescence scorpions acted like
they were in the dark.
There was no difference
between their behavior
and the dark and in UV light.
Whereas when UV light
was present for the ones
that can fluoresce, they
reduced their activity levels.
- [Derek] What's the conclusion from that?
- [Carl] The conclusion from that
is that the fluorescents
itself is acting as a way to,
for them to detect the
presence of ultraviolet light.
Another researcher by the
name of Douglas Gaffin,
came up with a great phrase for it.
I wish I'd come up with the
phrase, but I gotta give credit.
He calls it, a whole-body photon detector.
So it's part of their sensory system.
What we don't know is why they want
to detect ultraviolet light so badly
that they've turned their whole
body into a photon detector.
The suspicion is that it
has to do with determining
whether or not they
should come out at night.
- [Derek] The idea is when UV light hits
a scorpion's body, it
fluoresces and the tail detects
this emitted green light
alerting the scorpion
that it is exposed so
it searches for cover.
- [Carl] Scorpions are good at starving
for long periods of time.
They don't need to eat that often.
And coming out and foraging
is dangerous for them.
And so they don't like to come out
when it's a moonlit night.
Typically the only ones you'll
find out in the full moon
are the ones that are really
hungry, really need food.
If they're well fed, they'll stay down.
So they're using that
as basically their cue
in the environment and saying, you know,
okay, this is how bright it is.
So that's a cue as to how
likely I'm being preyed upon.
And then here's how hungry I am.
That's a cue how badly I need
to get out and get some food.
- [Derek] Right.
- [Dr. Carl] And then the
trade off between those two
is basically should I go out tonight
or should I stay in my hole.
- [Derek] Yeah.
(techno sound)
- If you like overpaying
when you shop well,
then don't listen to this next part.
But if you want to save
money, then keep watching.
Because this portion of
the video is sponsored
by Capital One Shopping,
a free browser extension
that will automatically
find the best deals
when you shop online.
It's just two clicks
to install and it works
on all major browsers.
Then whenever you shop,
it'll work away in the background,
comparing prices and testing coupons
to make sure you never
overspend on an item again.
As much as I want to save money,
searching for bargains and
coupon codes is a big hassle
and Capital One Shopping
lets you get the best deals
without having to waste any of your time
finding those deals in the first place.
They all apply automatically at checkout.
They even have their own shopping page
that gathers products from
across different sites
and picks out the cheapest ones
so you can shop directly for
the best deals on the internet
and you don't need to be a
Capital One customer to use it.
This extension is free
for literally everyone.
So you can start saving money right away.
I want to thank Capital One Shopping
for sponsoring this portion of the video.
And I want to thank you for watching.